[Music]
my name is Jocelyn I am a member of the
Voorhees Toastmaster Club District 38
and I am the world champion of the
public speaking for 2023. can you tell
me every emotion that is going through
your body right now
it's just surreal you ever have a wave
of just I can't believe this is
happening it's almost an outer body kind
of by him but it's just I'm excited I'm
ecstatic I'm a speechless and it's just
amazing what went through your mind when
you heard your name call this world
champion
first thing what what wait what me wait
me me
just me and I think that was the first
thing and and still feel like it's going
on right now is that can this be me but
I worked hard and it was a labor of love
so I'm just grateful just grateful
who helped get you to where you were
it was definitely family friends fellow
Toastmasters
non-toastmasters and just different
audiences that I was bringing the speech
to I just wanted to be
relatable to them and everyone when I
was giving that speech because I
practiced with them I spent time with
them and just pulled and cultivated this
thing and that's who I thought of and
just also having fun and remembering
that day and remembering what brought me
there and that that speech was my story
[Music]
thank you